ya sabemos que para formar un ángulo
necesitamos dos rayos por ejemplo un
rayo hacia allá y otro rayo digamos
hacia acá hacia acá el ángulo que se
forma es justo lo que queda entre esos
dos rayos déjame marcarlo en color
blanco sería algo de este estilo y
también sabemos que este punto que
tienen en común ambos rayos se conoce
como vértice le voy a poner aquí vértice
vértice y también sabemos que hay
diferentes ángulos no todos se ven igual
por ejemplo podríamos tener este de acá
y podríamos tener otro de este lado voy
a agarrar la herramienta de línea algo
de este lado que se ve un poco más
abierto entonces justo hasta el momento
hemos dicho que que este ángulo de acá
es más abierto déjalo marco estoy acá es
más abierto
y que este de acá es menos abierto menos
abierto abierto pero en algunas
ocasiones nos gustaría ser mucho más
específicos con realmente que están más
o menos abierto es un ángulo y por lo
tanto sería muy bueno poder medir los y
para medir ángulos hay dos formas
principales una es con grados le voy a
poner aquí grados grados
y la otra que quizás estudiaste después
en la preparatoria o en la secundaria es
con radiales sobre todo cuando estudias
cosas trigonométricas pero bueno ahorita
no nos vamos a meter con eso y
únicamente vamos a pensar en grados y la
forma en la cual uno mide ángulos con
grados es la siguiente todo empieza con
un círculo déjame poner por acá un
círculo algo de ese estilo y la
convención va a ser que un círculo tiene
360 grados 360 grados 360 esta bolita
quiere decir grados vale ahora esto de
que es una convención quiere decir que
así se ha hecho por todo el tiempo por
mucho tiempo y por muchas personas
porque son 360 y no otro número nadie lo
sabe con exactitud sin embargo en la
historia y en la naturaleza hay algunas
pistas de por qué sucede eso la mayor
conjetura que se tiene hasta el momento
es que si recuerdas la tierra tarda 365
días lo voy a poner por acá 365 días
díaz en darle la vuelta completa al sol
y por lo tanto eso está muy relacionado
con este 360 las culturas antiguas
usaban un calendario de 360 días por
ejemplo los mayas lo usaban y también
los persas entonces eso es una muy buena
aproximación para 360 y tiene ciertas
ventas ventajas es un número más bonito
es un número cerrado y además 360 tiene
muchos factores más es decir es
divisible entre muchos otros números
entonces se cree que por eso por eso un
círculo tiene 360 grados vale pero bueno
ahora sí para medir un ángulo lo que
vamos a hacer es lo siguiente vamos a
pensar que un círculo tiene 360 grados
vamos a colocar uno de los rayos
saliendo del centro voy a tomar la
herramienta de línea recta que si no no
me sale algo así vamos a marcar el otro
rayo digamos algo de este estilo
es algo de este estilo y para medir el
ángulo lo que vamos a hacer es tomar la
fracción correspondiente de 360 a la
fracción que es este arco de círculo con
respecto a todo el círculo déjame
hacerlo es decir aquí tenemos este
cachito de círculo que se conoce como
como un arco del círculo y lo que
tenemos que ver es qué proporción es
este cachito de todo el círculo para
medir el ángulo supongamos que esto es
de un sexto de todo el círculo entonces
si este arco es de un sexto la medida de
este ángulo va a ser de un sexto de 360
y por lo tanto la medida de este ángulo
va a ser de 60 grados vale bueno vamos a
hacer algunos ejemplos más déjame poner
por aquí otro círculo lo voy a poner
aquí un poco más a la derecha
voy a poner el centro por ahí y vamos a
marcar otro rayo algo de este estilo y
pensemos que ahora tenemos un segundo
rayo que voy a pintar en color verde que
va directamente hacia arriba algo así
algo de este estilo entonces cuanto
mediría este ángulo de acá si quieres
puedes detener el vídeo para pensarlo un
ratito pero ahorita ya lo voy a hacer
entonces cuánto sería bueno pues como
éste va hacia la derecha y este
totalmente hacia arriba este arco de
círculo este cacho de acá va a ser
exactamente una cuarta parte de todo el
círculo sería una cuarta parte y por lo
tanto la medida de este ángulo sería una
cuarta parte de 60 de 360 es decir 90
grados 90 grados y los ángulos que tiene
que miden 90 grados tienen un nombre
especial se llaman ángulos rectos
ángulos rectos
rectos y cuando tenemos dos rayos que
hacen un ángulo recto decimos que esos
rayos son perpendiculares vale vamos a
hacer un par de ejemplos más déjame
tomar otro círculo lo voy a poner por
acá vamos a pensar que por aquí está el
centro y que ahora tenemos la siguiente
situación uno de los rayos va hacia la
derecha algo así y el otro va hacia la
izquierda hacia la izquierda este es un
ejemplo muy interesante también te
recomiendo de tener el vídeo para que lo
pienses vale entonces el ángulo que nos
interesa es este de acá bueno ya lo voy
a resolver cuando mediría este ángulo de
acá pues mínima idea tenemos que ver qué
arco de circunferencia abre y en este
caso justo abre la mitad de la
circunferencia verdad abre toda esta
parte de acá toda esta parte de acá
que mide la mitad de la circunferencia a
la mitad del círculo y por lo tanto la
medida del ángulo va a ser la mitad de
360 grados voy a poner la mitad de 360
60 grados es decir este ángulo mide 180
grados entonces el ángulo que forma una
línea justo es de 180 grados vale y
déjame hacer un último ejemplo ese
último ejemplo lo voy a poner hasta acá
a la derecha voy a ponerlo algo así
déjame marcar el centro del círculo el
centro del círculo que está por ahí voy
a poner un rayo hacia la derecha y ahora
lo que voy a hacer es poner un rayo
hacia abajo hacia abajo este ejemplo
está interesante porque aquí se forman
dos ángulos de hecho siempre se forman
dos ángulos tenemos este ángulo de aquí
abajo este ángulo de aquí abajo
qué es de esto se acaba verdad es un
ángulo recto porque esto mide 90 grados
pero el que nos interesa ahorita es el
ángulo de arriba el que va en el sentido
en el sentido contrario a las manecillas
del reloj es decir nos interesa la
medida de este ángulo de acá cuánto
mediría este ángulo bueno pues el arco
que nos interesa es el que va de aquí
acá recorrido de este lado déjame
marcarlo así como
como así con rayitas sería todo esto de
acá todo esto de acá y todo esto y acá
sería darle tres cuartas partes de
vuelta a la circunferencia verdad este
es una guarda parte dos tres cuartas
partes de vuelta entonces esto sería
tres cuartas partes de vuelta por lo
tanto la medida sería tres cuartas
partes de 360 grados y cuando es tres
cuartas partes de 360 pues una cuarta
parte es 90 grados y 90 grados por 3 es
270 grados entonces este ángulo mediría
270 grados